West Virginia lawmakers are meeting
today to try to try to reach an
agreement to end the statewide teacher
strike this morning nearly three hundred
thousand students are out of class again
for the eighth day teachers are
protesting low salaries and rising
health care costs
vladimir duthiers from our streaming
network cbsn is here with why a deal
fell apart over the weekend lad good
morning good morning the state governor
and union leaders agreed to a five
percent raise last week but over the
weekend West Virginia Senate offered a
four percent raise in its place union
leaders call that deal unacceptable
saying they will continue to strike for
anything less than five percent teachers
in West Virginia say they're fed up
you're making it look like it's all
about money
sorry and it's not over the weekend the
state Senate knocked down an approved
teacher pay increase to give all public
employees an equal four percent raise
but the Union says it's pitting teachers
against other public employees we want
everyone to have equitable
reduce one because of another West
Virginia teachers are among the lowest
paid in the country with salary starting
at about $33,000 a year and the Union
says cost of living in the state has
gone up by nearly five percent since
their last pay increase four years ago
five percent doesn't even move us any
partner than where we should be so
bait-and-switch it's unacceptable West
Virginia's governor tweeted this weekend
that this wrangling needs to stop we are
putting our children at risk the strike
affects more than 270,000 students many
who live in poverty and miss out on free
breakfast and lunches when they don't go
to school volunteers have gathered food
to help students in need it is a tough
time for everybody and we just want to
do our part to make sure kids get some
food union leaders say they won't stop
until they reach an acceptable
compromise as long as this amendment is
out there with four percent we will stay
united and we will be out indefinitely
West Virginia's call for action has
inspired teachers in other states like
Oklahoma to organize their own walk outs
to fight for teachers rights as you said
students paying the highest price during
this debate thank you